hey everyone this is feed our master
Kosuke boots key here for chess calm and
today I wanted to start a new series
here on YouTube talking about how to
evaluate certain positions and the
common mistakes that players often make
when they want to evaluate a particular
position so basically the way it's going
to work is that I'm going to have one or
two examples every video and first thing
I'll do is I'll ask you to evaluate it
for yourself draw some kind of
conclusion and then I'll give you the
actual evaluation and we can discuss
some of the common pitfalls and errors
that players often make the position you
currently see on your board is the one
we're going to be talking about today
and I want you guys to evaluate it if it
was white to move and while you're doing
that I'm going to give a bit of pros on
some things that are important to think
about in terms of general chess
development so the first thing I want to
do is talk about the difference between
a mistake and evaluation and a mistake
in calculation so let's say you're
playing a game and you go for some
forcing continuation so you play one
move your opponent has a force response
you play your second move they have
another force response and then you play
your third move and the position you get
after your third move is the one that
you've seen ahead of time in your
calculations and you judge that position
to be good for you or much better or
even winning right and then after you
play your third move your opponent
suddenly play some tactic that you
missed or finds a fork or some small
combination you end up down a rook and
you lose the game so is that a mistake
in evaluating the position not really
it's more of a mistake in calculation
right it wasn't some defect in your
chest understanding you simply
overlooked some tactical operation or a
resource for your opponent now let's say
that you know you played that same
forcing operation and different game and
after your third
move your opponent didn't have anything
immediately concrete to win the game but
they played some natural moves and your
position ended up being worse so that
wasn't a mistake in calculation that was
a mistake in evaluation it was an error
in judgment and you misunderstood some
details in the position right maybe you
overestimated the power of something or
underestimated the power of another
factor in the position right so those
are the kinds of situations that I want
to talk about with what this series is
how to correct and improve your
evaluation skills so that whenever you
do go towards a certain position that
you're able to judge it correctly and
before we move on I do want to say that
evaluation is really tough skill that
even the best players in the world miss
evaluate positions all the time right
but the better you are then the more
accurate and precise your evaluation can
be okay enough with that let's talk
about this specific chess position in
front of you and if you need more time
and you want to think about it more then
please do pause the video and continue
thinking otherwise we'll move on and of
course when you're coming up with a
conclusion for yourself about the
evaluation of this position think about
who's better and by how much
so if why it's better for example then
is white completely winning you know
black should resign is white clearly
better or is why just slightly better
meaning if black plays good defensive
moves and they will probably make a draw
or is it equal in your mind or is black
better or is black clearly better
complete the winning I think you get the
idea okay so now we'll move on to the
actual evaluation of this position here
we have a material imbalance right
that's probably the first thing we
should notice why it has a rook versus a
knight and two pawns so normally this
would be equal in terms of the nominal
material account but since the pawns are
doubled
then usually double pawns aren't worth
as much as connected pawns and thus that
will lead us to believe that White has a
slight material advantage okay but what
else should we notice about this
position well whenever we're playing
with a rook against a knight or a bishop
the things you want to look for are
whose pieces can get active and whose
pieces can create more threats and
develop more play in this case White's
rooks aren't doing a whole lot and don't
have a whole lot of potential White has
to open files the e-file and the B file
so naturally the rooks would want to
work there if this were a goes to the
e-file well it's permanently blocked by
this bishop on e6 which looks passive
but is actually doing a very good job of
preventing White's rooks from getting
active and similarly if the rook goes to
b1 trying to activate itself on the B
file then well I can simply play rook b8
and White has no way of exploiting this
pin for example rook C one threatening
rook C 2 blocking just play Bishop by 5
and this rook has to go back in the
corner so that's no good for white right
so seeing that White's pieces don't
really have any kind of activity or
potential for activity that gives us a
hint that this position might not be
good for white even though they have a
material advantage and by the way this
bishop on g2 is also not very good
because it's pretty much as they say
biting on granite on this d5 pawn which
is perfectly protected perfectly solid
and that means that this bishop on g2
doesn't really have a whole lot to do
either so what about blacks position
does black have any sources of counter
play well yeah all black has to do is
just play King g7 King D 6 and C 5 and
they're going to have to connected past
pawns in the center which are going to
be really strong and
honestly there isn't really a way for
white to stop this plant so the actual
values from this position is that black
is clearly better if not completely
winning because White's pieces can't get
active and black in a few moves is going
to create a couple of connected passed
pawns in the center which are going to
be very strong so let me show you how
the game continued this was taken from
one of my own games I was playing black
hear my opponent played rook F c1 rook
b8 we should've f1 King g7 there should
be two Bishop f5 King f1 King d6 a for
rugby three
I'm simply activating all of my pieces
and getting ready to push c5 so Bishop
d1 I gave a check and although this
bishop is bad I decided to simply remove
it from the board just to make things
simpler for myself because now after c5
I mean my King rook and Bishop are all
perfectly placed to support these pawns
to advance and Queen and white is pretty
much lost at this point because they
have no play in no way of stopping my
pawns so rook e1 white wants to get some
activity and I could allow this I can
simply push the pawn and probably win
the game but I decided not to give my
opponent any chances and after rook a
for d4 would be a mistake because of
rookie 5 Czech and white wins this pawn
but simply I played f6 taking away the
e5 square and my opponent decided to
resign because he had no way of stopping
these pawns from pushing and promoting
and again my King rook and Bishop are
perfectly coordinated to support these
pawns and and why it is pretty much
helpless so what can we learn from this
example well the two typical mistakes I
want to talk about that players probably
make when they evaluate something like
this is first they focus too much on the
material count a lot of times when
players see a position where one side
has an extra pawn
they just assume well upon is upon and
that's good enough for an advantage they
overlook the dynamic features of the
position like whose pieces are more
active who has the easier to play stuff
like that the second mistake is that
players often underestimate their
opponents resources in this case if
you're looking at it from Whiteside you
might only try to figure out a way for
white to get active play or to create
some threats and you might have
completely overlooked or underestimated
blacks simple counter play of bringing
the King to the center and playing c5
and getting these two incredibly strong
past pawns
so hopefully you guys enjoy this lecture
and we will continue with evaluating
complex positions in the future thanks a
lot for listening and I'll see you
around on chess calm